darius how are you my friend what's up
my friend i'm i'm actually changing my
name to sunny swag officially as of
today feeling very swagged out i don't
know why but let's go sunny swag goo
i didn't know that we were going with
wrestling names here
jerome powell the honorable central
banker was asked recently
do you believe that inflation was caused
by the russia invasion of ukraine and he
to his credit said no inflation was
already pretty high before russia
invaded ukraine
and then the politician who asked him
said well why the hell is the president
keep saying that russia's invasion of
ukraine is leading to inflation
is this an important kind of data point
in that now that central bankers not
only are they saying it's not transitory
but they're being
honest it's like kind of a weird word
but they're at least being more
transparent about what they really think
are the drivers of inflation and they're
not just going with the talking points
of uh any one political party
yeah 100 man so i i feel bad for jerome
powell really any fair chair that has to
sit in front of our dysfunctional
congress and listen to what i believe
are the dumbest series of questions out
there i mean by joe but anyway so yeah
this whole inflation what's causing
inflation it's very clearly a political
football in dc and the reason it's a
political football is because we're
heading into a midterm elections where
i'm pretty sure the democrats are very
clearly going to get smoked uh as a
function of the the inflation the stock
market crash et cetera et cetera that's
a perfect recipe for for losing uh
the majority in the house and senate um
with respect to powell and this
inflation narrative he is being accurate
and this is something we've been talking
about on your program all year which is
the broadening out of inflation pressure
you know there's a couple statistics
i'll throw at the audience which is uh
the median cpi the federal reserve bank
of cleveland conti maintains a statistic
uh that shows the median price change
across all the different hundreds of
items in the cbi basket and on a median
basis it's up 6.4 on a three-month
annualized rate of change uh basis which
is the fastest rate of all time in the
time series going back to the early 80s
so we do have a problem with inflation
and it's broadening out and then with
respect to this whole russian ukraine
nonsense and let's put this to bed or at
least to put it to bed for the from the
depth of our audience inflation was at
7.5 in january of 2022 before russia
crossed the border and set foot into
ukraine two when you look at what's
actually driving inflation now at this
particular juncture it's now services
inflation core services inflation at
seven point eight percent on a
three-month annualized basis that's the
fastest number we've seen since uh the
mid 90s or sorry not the mid 90s the
middle of 1990
and so clearly it's you know these are
things that have very little to do with
you know rising food and energy prices
if you talk about you know the the how
much it costs to rent your home or or
get an airplane or go over in the hotel
room
so
another component of this is that he was
asked do you believe that the united
states is potentially headed towards a
recession
and he basically said yes
which goes
directly against the white house press
secretary saying they do not see a
recession being imminent
uh janet yellen saying she does not see
a recession imminent
and it feels to a degree
that jerome powell is kind of breaking
ranks he's being a little bit more
honest a little bit more uh rational
intellectually uh humble even maybe to
some degree
how do you start to analyze if a central
banker is doing that is he signaling
that it may be way worse than people are
thinking it could get or is he just
trying to keep his own personal
credibility so that when he leaves as
the federal reserve chairman uh he's got
other opportunities you know from his
kind of professional career
no a great question man and there's a
couple things i'll unpack towards the
end of this but the one thing i will say
is that he's actually not breaking ranks
don't forget uh i'm going to say last
month uh he treasury secretary janet
yellen and president biden huddled up
together in the oval office to decide
what would be the the sort of plan to
tackle inflation and more importantly
i'm assuming what was also going to be
their communication strategy and clearly
the communication strategy is from
yellen's perspective hey we got this
wrong we're doing something about it
from president biden's perspective it's
all vladimir putin and the fed's got to
do something about it and jay powell is
willingly um understanding that he's got
the full weight of the the credibility
of the federal reserve institution
behind him is effectively taking
responsibility uh being sort of the
scapegoat and ultimately having to be
the bad cop as it relates to getting
inflation under control um i sent you a
chart it might be a little bit too wonky
for this program but i tend to think
that everyone has the ability to to
learn and grow so can you thought that
chart um
powell's still fighting to maintain
control over the bond market uh do you
have that one yeah the last one you sent
us yeah how old is fighting to maintain
control over the bond market what is
this showing us yeah so the second panel
the the bottom chart is the more
relevant one for this discussion which
shows the term premium uh in in treasury
bonds so that's a very wonky specific
statistic but in in layman's terms what
it means is how much sort of extra yield
do bond investors need to get
compensated for to take the risk of just
owning a bond because there's all sorts
of different uh volatility with growth
expectations different volatility with
inflation expectations policy rate
expectations et cetera et cetera and
right now that term premium is a minus
six basis points um you go back to the
last time we had the fed lose its
credibility in the you know mid to late
70s all the way into the early 80s until
paul berger started to get it back uh
you saw that statistic go all the way up
you know four or 500 basis points and so
right now what this is telling you is
that the bond market still believes the
fed is going to do something significant
to get inflation under control which is
why powell feels comfortable being the
bad cop uh it'll be a lot more difficult
for him to be the bad cop if we were at
much higher levels on this chart i mean
at minus six basis points that's the
eighth percentile rating since going
back to the late 1950s so he's got a
decent amount of credibility he's got a
window to use it now if this window
closes and we don't get inflation under
control before the economy slows down
significantly then he's going to start
losing a significant amount of
credibility and that could be all hell
could be breaking loose in the bond
market so if we go and we take a look at
the the topping process uh you said
topping process is market
in-market-based inflation expectations
uh help people understand what a topping
process is and then how that relates to
these inflation expectations yeah great
question bob so so
topping processes so tops are generally
processes right like if you think about
like look at a chart of a stock picture
look at the chart of bitcoin right uh
you know actually bitcoin tends to have
these blow off tops it'll eventually
mature as an asset class but you look at
the chart of the stock market as an
instance they tend to sort of crest into
the peak and when you look at market
internals you tend to sort of lose
leadership along the way into the peak
and it's usually this sort of very
observed very measured process whereas
bottoms are usually catalyzed by some
sort of cathartic event and eventually
some sort of you know very aggressive
policy response to get you going in the
other direction so what i'm showing in
this chart here uh is two-year five-year
10-year and 30-year inflation swap rate
this is what the market the bond market
is betting inflation's going to be uh
over the average of those durations and
so that the clearly the bond market is
saying hey look we are no longer
comfortable pricing inflation
expectations up until the right off the
top of the chart anymore clearly
inflation on a reported basis is up and
to the right off the top of the chart
but the four looking you know sort of
martin going back to our discussion on
how markets are looking the bond market
is starting to say hey i think we're
starting to peak out in inflation
expectations terms which takes me to you
know sort of this next part of the
discussion which you were talking about
prior to me joining the program which is
this eventual transition to deflation
deflation going back to uh you know the
you know been on the program for a while
now but for those of you who are new you
know we run a sophisticated sort of
systematic regime segmentation process
at 42 macro to help investors manage
macro risk and one of those regimes is
called deflation that's where both
growth and inflation are slowing it
simultaneously you know that's you know
generally speaking it's a lot of what
you've seen on your screens year-to-date
uh could be a little bit worse for
certain asset classes but also a little
bit better if you think you know think
about bonds you know potentially
starting to rally but very bad for
things like physical commodities et
cetera and digital commodities etc and
so maybe this is a leading indicator of
that sort of eventual transition to
deflation which we must we must go to we
must go through in order to get to the
good stuff get back to the good times
so if you then take a look at uh this
like pivot uh that could potentially be
coming uh they claim they're not gonna
do it they claim they're gonna stay
steadfast there are appeals to the paul
volcker-esque era
and his uh his approach to markets and
inflation
what do you see here with the real yield
curve
yeah so so powell gave us a lot of
information which by the way this guy's
i know he's he's getting a lot of heat
for this inflation problem and you know
to a large degree you know he is
partially responsible for keeping his
foot on the gas uh last year amid all
that record fiscal stimulus but just in
terms of would you rather have janie
gellen alan greenspan or ben bernanke or
jay powell right now
james would rather have j-pop right now
are you kidding me yes
it's easy to dunk on them it is very
easy to dunk on because of the situation
but he is incredibly intelligent and i
actually think out of all the people you
just mentioned he's the most measured
and appears to be the most uh
unemotional about the market
because he's an investor he's guys worth
100 million bucks you're working at
carlyle you know he knows what he's
doing um so at the end of the day he's
very honest and he's given us a lot of
information in terms of what is
spooking the fed and ultimately what
might unspook the fed and so going back
to that real yo curve card there's two
charts that i'm that are effectively
sort of monitors i think investors
should be paying attention to to help
them understand when the fed might pivot
so this one right here we'll go back to
the other one so this right here
structural inflation expectations you
know he talked a lot about this sort of
five-year ford university of michigan
inflation expectation reading um that
jumped off the chart same day we got
that may cbi report um and so when you
look at where that statistic is
currently at four point three percent
you know we gotta basically break back
down 100 130 basis points on this
statistic to give the fed comfortable uh
credit or sort of you know quote unquote
clear and confirming evidence that core
pce is getting back to its target you
know it's target let's call it two and a
half percent on the upper boundary of
that that average inflation range um
going back to the previous chart the
real yield curve he said another thing
he wants to see in order to judge
whether or not financial conditions have
tightened enough to really give them
comfort before they even consider a
pivot which is real yields across the
entire treasury curve um and real yields
and so this is uh the 10-year sorry the
two-year five-year tenure and 30-year
across each of those panels a nominal
treasury yield deflated so subtracted uh
subtracting um the inflation swap rates
from each of those tenors and so right
now we're we finally started to achieve
it on the five-year and 10-year we've
been achieved it on the 30-year but
we're still quite a ways away about 110
basis points away on the two-year which
means they got they got you know some
more hikes to do and they got some more
job owning to do and they got more
quantitative tightening to do to give
them comfort that the bond market is
really starting to get under control
from the perspective of inflation
expectations and ultimately that'll
filter through the economy on the leg
so when you start to think about uh this
last chart you have here the powell
pivot monitor uh structural inflation
expectations uh one of my big questions
is um
if they are aggressive and they are able
to destroy demand which appears that
they are uh heading that direction and
successfully uh at least have some some
movement on
could we get stagflation like you
mentioned deflation earlier but is there
a world where inflation stays
persistently high and they also destroy
demand um in from an economic standpoint
we get some sort of stagflation
situation
yeah um so we will have some sort of i
mean depending on how you define
stagflation right um if you define
stagflation as above trend inflation and
below trend growth then yeah we're
definitely headed for stagflation i mean
there's no question about that if you
define stagflation as persistently above
trend inflation and persistently below
trend growth then i think that question
is to be to be determined if this fed is
comfortable sending us into something
that is more than a mild recession in
order to really kill inflation once and
for all then we won't have a persistent
stagnation if however you know we get to
a mild recession or something that looks
like that and the fed is really starting
to back off and stepping on the gas
pedal again then it's very likely we
have something that looks like
persistent stagflation so it's path
dependent it's very difficult to
ascertain to answer that question now
but i'm not really sure you need to
answer in that question now the next
major catalyst for financial markets is
this transition from inflation where
inflation's going up and growth is going
up in the market having to price that in
to deflation where both growth and
inflation are going down potentially
into a recession
so when you start to look at various
asset classes
what assets do you think are best
positioned if that's where we go
is it just cash
yeah is it cash or is it something else
no so uh cash is king right now when you
get into deflation you're going to
unlock the entire sort of global
sovereign debt market which has been a
hard sell really for the past you know
call it nine six nine months um and so
you know once you get into deflation
once the bond market is comfortable that
the inflation problem is being dealt
with that you know the doctor the
surgeon has successfully amputated the
gangrene foot then we're comfortable you
know sort of getting back in the pool
getting back in the water and so um
that's going to be the next big pivot
you're going to see in financial markets
is bonds really start to move uh to the
upside in price downside in yield and
maybe temporarily and i think so that's
i think what's happening today
particularly you know encrypt in the
crypto space you're seeing a significant
uh decline in long-term bond yields you
know really born out of the sort of
recession fears rising in europe um and
that's really kind of you know you know
cascading through global sovereign debt
markets including our uh cyber debt
market which by the way like week over
week we've lost like 40 basis points in
the 10-year treasury yield just like
that you know so when this move when the
stuff moves it moves and in the you know
the very near term bond yields going
down is the old sort of you know by
nasdaq by crypto trade right but
eventually it's going to be bond yields
going down sell nasdaq sell crypto
because i need more liquidity i need
cash and these things are not working
so vladimir putin president of russia
recently gave a speech
and i gotta say it may be one of the
most honest assessments of what's going
on right now and a lot of people will
discount it because vladimir putin's
saying it i want to uh put a huge
disclaimer uh myself
not a huge fan i'm assuming you're not a
huge fan either
but let's take away a uh for a second
who's saying it and let's look at what
is being said
and he said things like look the global
economic system has taken a blow the
united states levying the sanctions they
did against russia and taking the uh fx
reserves uh now has a lot of countries
around the world uh questioning whether
they need to keep their own
central bank reserves somewhere else or
in a different type of asset he talks
about the fact that the united states
went from a net exporter of food to a
net importer he talks about the money
supply has grown by 38 percent and the
amount of uh uh importing um is somewhat
related to that he talks about the eu
like i mean he just did like a crash
course almost a master class in
macroeconomics in this speech uh
describing are these people dumb is
essentially what he says and he's like
they are doing things that are actually
hurting them more than the people
they're trying to hurt
is this the canary in the coal mine like
if vladimir putin's saying this in
speeches
how do central bankers like do they just
like oh whatever putin says we don't
listen or are they acutely aware of the
situation
oh no i think they're acutely aware i
mean when you listen to guys like um
james to beat us who's uh former chief
commander of nato when he talks
obviously he's very plugged into the the
political artifice in dc
they you know he's talking about the
very same things which is you know the
sort of you know the two-sided risk
associated with you know you know
basically being very harsh on on on
russia and von putin for this ukraine
ukraine incursion um there is a range of
probable outcomes here and not the least
of which is the world's splintering from
the perspective of the currency system
you know the sort of deglobalization you
know you're going to start to see labor
forces really start becoming um more
sort of you know marginalized it's you
know the et cetera et cetera you know
we're moving into a world that's just
going to have structurally higher
inflation because there's going to be
more structural friction in terms of
transacting across borders um you know
you know you being able to use different
pockets and pools of labor we have
shrinking labor forces in places like
china and stuff anyway so that's going
to be an issue so i think he's
absolutely on to something i mean this
stuff's not gonna happen overnight right
like you know i remember when i was a uh
i was a kid you know i must have been in
i don't know like eighth grade or
something in in 2001 in the wto riots in
seattle and i remember thinking like man
this is a big deal but i didn't really
understand the full consequence in the
full scope of why it was a big deal it
was just you know people were getting
killed it was a really big deal at the
time turns out
hey we shipped most of our manufacturing
jobs to china when they joined the wto
in 2001. so looking back 20 something
years later it was obviously a big deal
and i think you know from today looking
forward into you know 20 40 something
we'll look back on the big deal and say
man when they did that thing with the
russia reserves and really splintered
the whole global currency system it'll
be pretty clear from that perspective
but right now you know looking forward
it's gonna it's gonna take time there's
gonna be all these different um
processes so you can't put the whole
trade on today expecting to make money
on a two decade long you know kind of a
catalyst but we definitely are moving in
that direction
when you start to look at financial
markets uh bonds and most fixed income
just absolute
trash frankly uh but all of the
foundations the endowments the pension
funds they've got huge huge allocations
to this fixed income
is there a world where that will
actually prove to be a smart investment
over the next decade or is it a world
where actually this idea of like a 60 40
global portfolio a huge allocation of
fixed income like all of these things
that maybe were considered modern
portfolio theory-esque
people are gonna have to unlearn and
actually learn a different way of
investing uh given the macro environment
and some of the things that we're seeing
uh central banks do
yeah so i gotta tip my cap to uh peter
atwater um who's on the top traders
unplugged podcast recently who talked
about sort of the souring global mood
and how that's likely to lead to
deglobalization and among other things
is likely to lead to sort of a reigning
in of of sort of fantastical investment
you know opportunities and part of the
reason we've had such fantastical
long-duration speculation in asset
markets is because of we've seen
multiple decades of disinflation of
globalization of demography all these
sort of major factors that have
contributed to lower and lower inflation
easier and easier monetary policy at
every juncture right we are no longer in
that in that mantra we're going to have
higher highs and higher lows in
inflation higher highs and higher lows
and bond yields and sort of higher lows
and lower lows and lower highs in
anything associated that needs bond
yields to go down to work um you know i
don't want to say you know crypto is is
is part of that that um fully part of
that that sort of amalgamation but it is
definitely something that's really
benefited right so you know i think when
you look forward for the next 10 years i
don't even do you should not by the way
don't ever listen to somebody talk about
10 years from now if you if someone has
a process to consistently predict 10
years from now then they shouldn't be
telling you anything they should be
counting money on a yacht in the
mediterranean right no one knows what's
going to happen for 10 years or not but
we can get we can ascertain based on
these big trends we can analyze trends
so going back to analyzing the trends
it's very likely the next 10 years of
investing are very different than the
last 10 years in the last 10 years as
you know crazy federal reserve balance
sheet expansion interest rates at or
below zero on a real basis consistently
throughout every major economy and even
some major emerging market economies
to a world where the scarcity of
resources scarcity of labor higher rates
of inflation bond yields are trending
higher not trending lower and that just
makes your asset allocation decision
making very very different than had
been the concept of 60 40 maybe it's not
dead but will it have to go to 60 30 10
or 60 20 20 to make room for things like
real assets real estate etc bitcoin i
don't know but i think it's going to be
very different i think if you're sitting
here today in a 60 40 style portfolio
and you got 10 years to retirement best
of luck with that
so i agree with everything you're saying
the one variable that uh i keep coming
back to bitcoin mark mobius uh i think
they say his name uh he's a previous
bitcoin skeptic he was recently on
television absolutely interesting he is
he seems like he should be all in on
bitcoin like he's such a long-term bull
he he he uh he previously was but what
he said was uh he thinks that bitcoin is
a lead leading indicator now and he
thinks that it has a very significant
psychological impact on markets
and i agree i agree when i come back to
the asset
it sounds a little crazy to say but it
feels like bitcoin is the most free
market macro asset we have and if that
is the case it is likely to be something
that has to be in everyone's portfolio
right
it's the first thing i check every
morning is the first thing i check on
saturday mornings is the first thing i
check on sunday mornings because it's
the only free market out there every
other market is grossly manipulated some
form or fashion either by regulation
central banks fiscal authorities some
form or fashion it's the cleanest market
we have today so yes of course i agree
when you think about that
obviously price can signal sentiment
shift or uh or kind of shifts in the
market
if it is the cleanest market we have
does that mean that many of these
investors eventually say i gotta have it
in the portfolio or
just because it's the cleanest market
doesn't necessarily mean that people
will allocate to it
uh i think people want to allocate to it
i haven't i don't talk to too many
institutional investors at this point
that are sort of
on the other side of the trade they just
might not be regular from a regulatory
standpoint allowed to put the trade on
in size right like you know it's very
very difficult for citadel or blackrock
to you know allocate significant chunks
of capital hundreds of billions of
dollars of capital if not trillions to
something like bitcoin right one it's
extremely volatile but two there's no
real regulatory framework or real
understanding of what would happen if
things go wrong right like we assume
things aren't going wrong and you know
you know we're all believers watching
the show here but something in theory
could go wrong like what if the network
was hacked something like that you know
i don't know then so like the wall
street needs the sort of certainty
associated with okay if something goes
wrong here's how we deal with it in the
legal system here's who gets their money
back first here's who gets their money
back second third and so on and so forth
so you know this is that's kind of the
main
issue with something like bitcoin and
why it's been sort of a slower moving
adoption phase from an institutional
investment standpoint as opposed to what
i think is a very clear and obvious we
should be in this asset i mean i don't
haven't talked to a hedge fund portfolio
manager or mutual fund portfolio manager
that doesn't have personally allocated
to bitcoin but they can't do it in their
funds and for a variety of regulatory
reasons
so
my last question for you
is uh earlier when i was talking about
uh bitcoin as an inflation hedge on the
way up and people moving capital before
inflation shows up
bitcoin coming down along with other
assets i stated that it was in
anticipation of the fed destroying
demand pulling down inflation and people
moving their capital uh elsewhere
after i've said that publicly pretty
much all of these
nice term nerds uh in the traditional
financial system
are like look at this idiot look at this
[ __ ] what are they talking about like
all this stuff
how do you view
the fed stepping in being hyper
aggressive with interest rates raising
quantitative tightening on the horizon
if not already started
and
bitcoin or other assets coming down
how do you kind of relate that to the
anticipation of future market conditions
versus uh no these are all just
speculative tools and uh uh the bitcoins
are stupid
yeah so like i'm looking at bloomberg
now we just lost
twenty fifteen twenty dollars in oil in
like a week
into a price of oil so like how is that
any different than bitcoin pricing and
eventual transition to deflation you
know i i don't know i think nerds is
probably too nice of a phrase to talk to
anybody who doesn't understand that
financial markets are for looking and
anticipatory right like if you're
talking to somebody who's in traditional
finance that thinks that's wrong they're
not going to be in traditional finances
very long so i wouldn't worry about too
much about their their commentary um but
yeah no so you're absolutely right look
the market is sniffing out and this
started last wednesday in my opinion
with the federal reserve press
conference with jpal's press conference
i live tweeted the event everyone go
back and check the event and i think
what's happened is the market finally
figured out that this is a federal
reserve as we've been saying on your
program and every piece of research i've
been writing all year that there's a
federal reserve that's comfortable
slowing the economy enough to get rid of
inflation and that is very different
than the federal reserve reaction
function the regime that we're exiting
which is a federal reserve that anytime
we had a hiccup on the growth side or
hiccup in financial markets that became
their number one priority their only
priority right now is dealing with
inflation and they're going to have a
mop in the closet to clean up the mess
whenever the mess comes afterwards
i am
i think that bitcoin at twenty thousand
dollars
right now
is showing
much more
resilience
and gives me much more confidence about
how it will perform in the future
than when it was at 69 000
because
it's down 70 percent right stocks are
down bonds are down real estate
everything's down
but when you look around the room
and you ask
people what do you want to own
for the next 10 years
it brings me back to
november of 2018
and
we issued a million dollar
challenge anyone on wall street pick any
asset
we'll take crypto
not one person
picked a single asset
and if they had
we today would still be up like 650
percent
percent
five percent look and it already crashes
that tells you everything you need to
know people will talk talk talk on
twitter and talk some more because
that's where people go to talk but what
happens in their portfolio is a very
different story what happened you know i
i'm telling you that i haven't talked to
anybody in a long time on the
institutional investment side that is
structurally short bitcoin you know i
think people get at the trade they get
the joke and certainly anybody who's
doing as much analysis as we're doing
understands how these big cycles are
turning from a growth inflation and
policy standpoint d globalization et
cetera et cetera understands that fix
the the the
market allocation to fixed income and
associated allocations to mega cap thing
type names and everything that was sort
of highly correlated to that that
allocation that market allocation was
wrong the valuations associated was
wrong the price was wrong and we're
seeing it on our screens today so we're
in the middle of a big phase transition
from a structural perspective that is
also sort of getting tied up in the
cyclical aspects of the economy as well
if you talk about inflation and maybe
potentially heading into a recession
i um
uh i'm not going to name names here but
i'm going to consider screenshotting all
of these tweets and then make a little
video later send them my way man you
know
we're gonna go we're gonna make a uh
we'll make a little video
and then we're going to uh wait
and i'll set like a calendar invite for
like uh three years four years from now
maybe two and a half short bitcoin the
whole time which is big makes no sense
yeah yeah
and uh no comment
the whole time like since like between
2009 like yeah yeah yeah
yeah no comment um all right uh where
can we send people to find you on the
internet
yeah no i'm at 42 macro detail on
twitter 42macro.com come check us out
you're serious investor we got serious
research for those who don't like
getting blown up cheers
all right my friend i appreciate it very
much i always enjoy these conversations
uh the beautiful thing about financial
markets is there's a lot of people with
opinions on the internet but uh if they
go and they look at the scoreboard i
don't think almost any of them have
outperformed bitcoin over uh the last
two years so
um you know hundred percent you you're
you're a football player too whenever
you have some jamock on the field
talking after you're destroying them
what do you say you just point to the
scoreboard
scoreboard jump get back to the hall and
then wait wait wait wait even just go
back
get back to the auto chop all right all
right we'll talk next week dares i see
you man be good brother later